oh what do you have there Professor
fren this is the experience Machine by
Andy Clark my friend Andy Clark oh
wonderful um I I started reading it
actually yes I can see you're on page 17
so so how's that going for you really
really good um I was reading it and I
was um quite struck by some of the
similarities to um to active inference
actually yeah and um in the first
chapter he's he's talking all about how
in the olden days we used to think of
the brain as a kind of cartisian theater
where signals come in and you have these
ref kind of refinements of
representations and then there's this
mind presumably then there's some kind
of infinite regress but of course
neuroscientists knew about all of these
back Connections in the brain and um I
guess this is where you came on car that
this whole new way of thinking about
brains as prediction machines came about
yeah yeah he I regard him as a brother
in arms so he he's he's the philosopher
I'm the sort of physicist theoretician
but effectively I think we're telling
the same story but you he's a beautiful
writer um and also just pick up on that
sort of um is the brain extracting
information from its sensorium or is it
a constructive or
creating generating expectations and
predictions hypotheses in which to
basically make sense of the world he has
a wonderful way of explaining that so he
says look the 20th century was very much
of a sort of outside in view of the
brain it was all this information coming
in and somehow in some hierarchal
recursive way you'd extract the right
meaning from that information but course
nowadays in the 21st century the story
is exactly the converse one of Dan
dennit strange inversions it's very much
an inside out process generating with
exactly those backward connections you
you mentioned before generating
predictions
explanations is this the right way of
explaining what I'm sensing and if it is
then your predictions match your
Sensations job done and if it's not oh I
changed my mind and basically this is I
think
yes I was pleased and honored to write
one of the um one of the verbs for this
and actually use the phrase this is a
book that grabs you and literally
changes your mind there a nice
coincidence and I've just noticed yeah
little story about Andy so and if I
remember correctly Andy started at
Sussex University um with a good and
great like um Margaret Bowden and then
um after an itinerant and glorious
career involving America ended up in
Edinburgh which he loved but he couldn't
surf in Edinburgh so he's always wanted
to get back to Brighton back to susex
and a few years ago
um Anil Seth who's himself at Sussex who
I noticed here is also ROM lovely blur
I'll just read that a predictably
groundbreaking expiration of the
predictive basis of our extended Minds
from one of our deepest and clearest
think
the experienced machine delivers a
remarkable combination of profound
insight and practical relevance so
Anil was very um pleased with himself
and I remember joyfully declaring when
he actually secured Andy Clark or head
hunted him from Edinburgh back to Sussex
so they could well I say they um Andy
and Alexa could go surfing again and I
remember that the the point at which he
got confirmation of Andy's head hunting
we were actually trapped during a b what
they call a medicane a hurricane in the
Mediterranean on a little Greek island
drilling down I think it was on um the
mathematical basis of Consciousness yeah
and we were in communicado with the
waves raging outside and Anil Seth was
playing the piano and he got this phone
call to confirm that he'd managed to
secure de
chair at Sussex several years ago so
from what I understand Andy is now
happily is it a cognitive philosopher
yes I'm I'm incredibly jealous of of his
job title A cognitive philosopher that
would be my aspiration one day to be a
cognitive
philosopher yep surfing and
philosophy so yeah he emailed me about
this um must have been before Christmas
saying he he had written a pot boiler uh
would would I like to just look you pass
my uh read through it briefly I had to
Google what a pot boiler meant
apparently it's it's a it's a a a brief
and cheerful book to make
money so it was beautifully written uh
but then I had to reread it to write the
blur but it's it's certainly more than
more than a pop boiler It's actually an
interesting synthesis of um I think
where that style certainly Andy's style
of thinking about life and making sense
of the lived world and physically um
engaging with that world where he was
prior to predictive processing and
active inference before the sort of um
the pragmatic turn or the inactivist um
shift you has been moved from the 20 to
21st century so before that he was you
know he was famous so things like the
extended mind um you know the designer
environment that you know that we in the
spirit of sort of Niche construction we
actually create our own Niche we create
our own environment in a way that makes
it much more predictable and affords the
opportunity now to sort of download a
lot of our cognitive capacities into the
world like our memories are now in our
iPhones and then he's basically taken
those foundational
and fundamental ideas and contextualize
them in the context of so modern
predictive processing an active
inference you know and this is the
synthesis a lovely read I wanted to pick
up on something you just said though
because when I was reading the book I
was rather struck by this idea that we
live in a
hallucination uh which is conditioned by
actual sensory information but let's say
90% hallucination and 10% sensory
information and from an enactivism point
of view what's really interesting about
that school of thought is that we create
the world that we live in as as well as
the world creating our own kind of
sensorium and that's just something that
really struck me as being quite
interesting what's your take on this
living a hallucination well I yeah you
said 90% uh hallucination and 10% I I I
I probably to 100% but um you that's
absolutely right so you know if you
believe that everything that we perceive
as being real is a hypothesis you know
uh the product of a constructive organ a
statistical organ you a little scientist
that just is our brain then all you're
saying is that the sensory data are just
in the service of confirming that
hypothesis or this alternative
hypothesis or or another hypothesis the
key observation being it's all
hypotheses it's all fantasy so you know
using the fantasy word is nice because
it means that the brain is literally a
fantastic organ it's a purveyor of um a
device for basically adjudicating
choosing the right hypothesis has the
best fit to this sensory data but of
course as you point out um it's not just
the fact we are sessile brains creatures
phenotypes that are delivered of data
Andy Clark would would Express in terms
of this your know sort of outside in
process we actually have to actively
select those data by moving by palpating
with our fingers by moving our eyes
around we are in charge of the data that
we now solicit to verify or disconfirm
our hallucinations or our hypotheses so
that's the inactive part that's the sort
of you know actively engaged in a way
that induces this kind of circular
causality
so you know we are certainly constrained
by our sensory data we
are our predictions and
hypotheses are informed by and
contextualized by sensory data but at
the same time the ensuing hypotheses
underwrite the way that we sample the
next bit of data so there's this
wonderful sort of autodidactic you know
physical engagement with you know with
with the lived world yes yes but I would
love to um understand where the autonomy
comes from and and the reason I'm asking
this question is there have been many
papers on chat GPT recently that have
essentially built an outer loop to find
different prompts so if you think of GPT
as an information matrial system there's
an outer loop to explore prompts in the
neighborhood of the original prompt and
this is very similar to what you're
saying from the enactive point of view
now there are books about how we think
with our bodies and you just said that
there's an an outer loop that says well
I now need to explore with my physical
body in my physical environment to get
more information to do inference and
what process is doing that outer
loop what so I
guess the body is in and of itself just
a
hypothesis um
and therefore the answer to your
question um it can't be that the self is
if you like
driving this active engagement this sort
of active learning and active um
inference about the way the world works
if it is the case that the self is
actually emerging from or a an
explanation we bring to the table to
explain all of these data so there must
be something underneath that um and um
as a true Bas in static ition uh your my
answer would be there are some prior
there's some prior belief and I don't
mean belief in a sort of folk psychology
sense I just mean in terms of some um
probabilistic distribution some
probabilistic specification of what it
is to be something like me and then
something like me goes around self-
evidencing acquiring sensory data that
um supplies evidence for my model of
this world and I suddenly have the
hypothesis well this world actually con
includes me as an agent as an artifact
and then I develop a sense of self so I
guess your question is where does where
does the autonomy come from as a
mathematician it comes from autonomous
differential equations that underwrite
the
itinerancy and the um technically the
you the attracting sets of the
attractors that characterize me that
specify the characteristic states that I
will uh
remaining so technically speaking I can
if you like elude the question about
where does autonomy come from where it
comes from autonomous differential
equations that characterize an
attracting set of characteristic states
that make me and you could actually
simulate that you can simulate all sorts
of things that have this sort of btic
aspect you know walking talking writing
all of these basically being um a
physical realization or instantiation of
these autonomous dynamics that you know
in a very straightforward way physically
realized by our neuronal Dynamics
however I suspect that your word use of
the word autonomy was was not quite not
quite wasn't so U technical or
deflationary um I think that the you
know to be
autonomous um first of all is to be a
kind of thing a particle or person that
can act upon the world so I think you
know there's a minimal or um requirement
that you have various states that change
the states on the outside of you that
are external to you that are extrinsic
that are um hidden behind your
Sensations your sensory veils um that
are latent in the sense that you'll
never observe them observe them directly
so to be autonomous is to be able to
move but there's clearly more to it in
the sense that if you're trying to um
explain your inactive or active
engagement with the world in terms of
making sense of the world you're
basically describing active inference
you're describing EV EV an Evidence
Gathering machine you're describing
self-evidence as Yakov howi um was would
would uh express it another um brother
in arms and a friend of Andy Clark's uh
and another I guess he'd probably be
very pleased to call himself a cognitive
philosopher um but he you know um Jacob
um sort of
has not invented but certainly repurpose
the notion of self- evidencing um as
a a very succinct and neat way to
describe this kind of predictive
processing that has this active
engagement in active flavor for me that
would be active inference and what is it
well it's just basically Gathering
evidence from my morals of the lived
world
so then you say well okay what
underwrites this evidence Gathering it's
the generative model it's the model um
that you are gathering evidence for and
you're continually updating that model
and I mean generative model exactly in
the spirit of generative AI um that
there is an implicit and possibly
sometimes explicit model that you are
gathering evidence for and that model
affords the opportunity to generate the
kind of content that um um will be
generated or observed under that model
and hence you you can look at generative
AI in large language models exactly you
know in in in that in that spirit so the
question now reduces in terms of where
does it where does autonomy come from it
really comes from the genitive model
where does that come from well it comes
probably from your mom and dad uh in two
senses not just your epig genetic and
epigenetic specification but also so the
sort of cultural Niche construction the
way that you're brought up so that you
have if you like a specification of the
characteristic states that make you a
good son or a good daughter or a good
consp specific um that
now undergird the generative model and
then you seek evidence for your model
and you learn the particular
specialization on the parameters of your
model by being brought up properly and
by being autodidactic later on in this
in or the autonomous sense or showing
the autonomy that comes along with self-
evidencing they I've try to get autonomy
into as many
different sentences as possible for you
beautiful beautiful